novel BCL2 inhibitor, and we'll talk about data in mantle cell lymphoma.
So before we're talking about the novel BCL2 inhibitor, we're going to review data real quick
for the first in-class BCL2 inhibitor of needle flax in mantle cell. The first data actually came
from the first inhuman paper by David. In that paper, there was a small number of mantle cell
patients included, which were PTK inhibitor naive. The response was 75% was 21% CL. The
median PF was 11. So it's really decent data. But this drug didn't move forward. There's some
historical challenges with some... The way the trial was done, then the partner drug was pulled
off the market and whatever. We're not going to talk about that today.
And then in real world study, there's some off-label use of
needle flax. Toby Iyer published the UK experience with 20 patients. 53% response rate was 18% CR.
The PFS is really disappointing, only 3.2 months. Then Yazeed, you have the data here with
either single agent or combination in relapsed mantle cell lymphoma.
Most patients with PTK inhibitor exposed. In this series, the overall response rate 40%,
CR 16%. The PFS was equally disappointing, only at 3.7 months.
So how does Sunrel compare to needle flax? It's more potent. As we heard from the talks
in the last couple of days, 14-fold more potent. It's also six-fold more selective versus BCL2XL.
The half-life is shorter. So that potentially can make the TRS monitoring a little
simplified. But the dose ramp-up is a little still confident. We still need to figure that out. But
at least you don't need to monitor the TRS labs at 12 or 24 hours.
So this is the 2-0-1 study of needle flax in relapsed mantle cell lymphoma. Patients must
have had a prior PTK inhibitor. So this trial had a part one with dose escalation and safety
expansion, and then part two for efficacy expansion at the ideal dose. So this is the patient population.
You can see a typical relapsed mantle cell population, elderly, male predominance.
87% of the patients were refractory to the last line of therapy. It really speaks to the difficult
to treat cohort nature. In terms of high risk features, you see a 42% patient had a high K67,
35% had TBG3 mutation. Close to 60% had three or more K67 mutations. As you can see, a lot of patients
were refractory to the last line of therapy, really speaks to the difficult to treat cohort nature. In terms of high risk features, you see a 42% patient had a high K67, 35% had TBG3 mutation. Close to 60% had three or more K67 mutations. As we heard from the talks in the last couple of days,
In terms of risk features, you see a 42% patient had a high K67 mutation. Close to 60% had three or more K67 mutations. As we heard from the talks in the last couple of days,
all lines of therapy previously and all of them had a PTK inhibitor and 20% had actually two or more PTK inhibitors.
So in terms of safety, the most common O grade treatment emergent AE
were hematological or something related to tumor cell apoptosis. And you can see on the right,
the neutropenia, thrombocytopenia, anemia, the hematological AEs were pretty frequent.
And then you have electrolyte abnormalities related to some component of TLS. TLS did happen
in eight patients and by definition, those are all grade three or above, but only two were clinical,
six were in laboratory, and all of these resolved without any issues. Infections are frequent,
39% and 16.5% were grade three. So it's not necessarily very easy to deal with.
In terms of efficacy, the response rate is 52%.
This is only looking at a patient in the part two, the efficacy expansion part.
The CR rate is 15.5%. If you only look at the response rates, probably similar to needle clax
data. The subgroup analysis in terms of response rate, you can see this high response rate of about
50% across pretty much all groups. And just highlighted, even for patients
with TPH3 mutation, the response rate is close to 60%. The one subgroup that had maybe slightly
lower response rate at 41% is the folks with high MIPE scores, about one third of the patients.
In terms of time to event data, the figure shows your duration response, not progression-free
survival. So duration response median is 16 months. Median progression-free survival is 6.5 months.
It's not fantastic, but numerically better than what we saw with needle clax in BTK-exposed setting.
Median overall survival has not been reached.
So how do these efficacy data compare with other BCL2 inhibitors or other available therapies?
So this is another BCL2 inhibitor that was presented to ASH this year.
The trial was done in China. The response rate in this small cohort appears to be very high, 84% and
36% CR rate. Median progression-free survival is 8 months. So it looks quite promising, but
we don't know a lot of the details of the patient population there, and
especially prior lines of therapy and all of that. So we'll see whether they have expansion.
I'm not sure this drug will come to the United States anyway.
Peritoneal was approved. Response rate, if you guys recall, is about in the 50% range as well.
Median progression-free survival is 7 months. Overall survival looks pretty good.
But putting all these together, so seronoclax can, mind you, the response rate 52%, 60% CR,
median PF is 6.5, comparing that to Pertol, very similar. So how do we choose?
Seronoclax may be getting an accelerated approval label real soon. So how do I choose?
I would like to use both. So I'm not going to, you know,
keep the conversation with the sponsors. We should do a trial with the combination.
That's it. Thank you.